Speaker 1: We are taking calls
through The David Pakman Show discord,
which you can find at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. Let's go next to
Bethany from Oklahoma.
Speaker 4: Bethany.
OK, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Perfect. I was wanting to talk about
gun control because I hear a lot of my liberal
friends talking about banning AR 15s and. Rivals
like that, but the truth is that we don't actually
have to ban them, and I only learned about this
because of my proximity to the South. Essentially,
I live in Oklahoma, but things like. Full, fully
automatic machine guns, those are actually illegal
to get if you go through the process
of getting a class three weapon and
and is there something I think progressives
should talk about more because like silencers,
those are class three weapons also. And so what
people have to do to get them is they have to
pull off the top. They have to pay like a two
hundred dollar tax on top of what they were
going to pay. But then they also have to go
through about a six month waiting period. I
think that might change from state to state.
But one of the most important things is you
have to meet with a police officer and so you
have to be interviewed and they just ask you,
you know, what is your like plan for this?
What are you going to do? Is sure. And
yeah, and I know people who have gone
through that process, and it seems
it just seems like a really reasonable process for
someone to go through who's getting an AR 15 gun.
And I know that there's there are lines blurred
between what hunting rifles are and what
the military styled weapons are. And that's
where the gun industry does need to be held
accountable a little more. They probably need
to, you know, not blur those lines as much.
But overall, I feel like that is just such
a great compromise that the two sides could
come to, because I just I hear liberals just
saying, ban them, ban them, ban them. Well,
what if we kind of start with that narrative,
but then we come to, well, OK, we won't ban them,
but let's make them a class three weapon instead?
Yeah, I just don't hear that that narrative on
a large scale. And I don't understand why.
Speaker 1: I don't know why either. I mean,
I think that it would make more sense to
take a sort of all of the above approach
in terms of hoping to get something done because
you're not going to be able to do everything you
want to do. At the same time, if the left tried
to work on all of these angles at the same time,
the right would just even further say, look at all
of the different ways in which they are trying to
take away your guns. But I completely agree with
you that there are things that can be done without
banning certain types of weapons that may get
us not not 99 percent of the way to the goal,
but maybe 75 or 80 percent. I think the other
thing that also sometimes the if we're if we're
talking about things, maybe the left is missing.
The rifles that are often used in mass shootings
are completely different from
the handguns that are involved
in in what are actually the greatest number of
gun related homicides and other deaths which are
individual or one or two people are injured or
killed. And very often the left will sort of
talk about the mass shootings and the individual
homicides and suicides as if they need to be dealt
with in the same way. And and this allows
the right to very quickly say, you know,
when you give us the full number of people killed
by guns, when almost all of them are handguns and
all you talk about is assault weapons, it doesn't
really make sense. And they're right about that.
And so I think that one area where the left
on guns could also do significantly better
is better distinguishing that the mass shootings
and the guns used for those are one problem. And
then the individual and two person homicides and
suicides and the gun use, there are a different
problem and they require different solutions.
Speaker 4: Yep, I totally agree. Yeah,
I think that handguns and I don't I don't know all
the answers for the handgun problem, but I know
a lot of it deals with kids not having access to
them. And, you know, at such a young age. And when
I read some article lately that was talking about
when parents are held more accountable for minors
getting their hands on guns and then,
you know, tragedy resulting from that,
I guess holding parents accountable can can make a
difference. I guess that depends on the state. I'm
I'm not exactly sure on all that, but, yeah,
there's definitely work to be done on that side.
And you're right, I never really hear the left
talk about that either. Yeah, it's a great point.
Speaker 1: All right, Bethany, thank you so much
for the call. Thank you. All right. Take care